poof days out I repeat the greatest game
of all time is finally here
hope deep it's a game about me this is
actually my origin story we announce
this in February last year and we've
been perfecting the poops
we've been molding them we've been
shaping them and it's time to finally
give birth to the first child this game
is free so download it right now a bit
of Unepic news for us when we submitted
the game Apple thought this game was too
stinky for whatever reason it's all
cartoony but apparently this game is too
stinky for Apple it's only out for
Google Play right now we're working to
fix that let's mark the game so the game
has agreed his intro of all time with
the greatest voice acting of all time
very very deep beneath the dark kingdom
of gramps lived a little worm no one
cared about was his name it's me
everyone was always laughing at poop tee
because of his farting problem I'm not
gonna lie the void second English he dug
himself a little hole and laid down in
this pond of Tears
but suddenly in the hopeless pit an
unexpected stranger appeared don't be
sad I'm the mighty book doc I have come
to tell you he's mayor don't withhold
your farts you will give birth great
miracles evil Sam run is casting dark
spells from its butt thrown and vicious
creatures are walking through the lands
things are about to change my tiny hero
but remember with big poop comes big
responsibility
now go poop with big poops comes great
toilets you've all heard it here first
glad you left that stinky pit child now
eat three core kit that's carrot and
read the poops girl okay will do
game play extremely intuitive could not
be better
greatest game of all time I don't want
to be biased or anything all right
there's one no I can't get through pond
of poop these tears
uh-huh I can't poop this is so sad oh
here we go hey we got the ability to
poop warm inside and out though not as
soft as it seems good for close range
comment and moving obstacles the more
you know here all this time I just been
flushing poop out of my toilets here we
go ready to poop there it is
so cute now I can use my poops to
command and do my bidding Thank You poop
Hey look at that more carrots we need
more resources to poop more however but
we'll get there so the best way I would
describe this game dungeon crawler type
adventure game minion minion controller
question mark hey now we can make
another poop nice this is truly the
greatest game to play on the toilet okay
so here's our first enemies the buck
crawlers they're not very tough but the
game just amp up very quickly those
nasty bug crawlers have eaten my crops
just when I was about to cook myself a
soup this is so sad alright we can do
that it's the kind of game where you're
rewarded for looking around a bit more
there's definitely always a ton of stuff
hidden and you definitely want to keep
resources going for later in the game
I've seen some reviews for the game so
far it seems like really positive it
does have some problems that we're
obviously working on maybe there's some
glitches or whatever it is it is a game
made by two people after all so
hopefully they'll be understanding but
it is super fun ok what do I got that's
so cute
all right times Boop when you're out of
poop just poop more you heard it from me
first
there we go we cleared the backyard
gamers don't call yourself a real gamer
unless you play poop 500 hours okay I am
cleaning out all this area I don't have
required poop construct additional
pylons so this is a place you can come
back later when you have more of the
right poops it's such a weird sentence
yeah alright let's go through the
butthole oh god it continues I must be
gone now remember that each poop you
make is a fertilizing tear dropping on
the tormented soul of our kingdom the
story is very deep okay the hug speed
poop dug is my hair I'm not gonna lie
I'm not gonna sit here and tell you lies
that I don't want to marry poop dog
instead
alright let's clear out all right we're
in poop town this is our sort of main
area in the game let's talk to this guy
see squish all the vermin great but the
crops are users anyway my store will
open for you but please try to withhold
your vain Birds go talk with bull I can
see he's worried this land so we can buy
carrots from him and wood which we used
to make Jesus Christ what is that photo
I have not seen that one before
item frenzy ok vermin talk to Bolin
pooped on alright so this is the bowl
this is where Edgar lives I'm the lead
bearer of the remain level 120 but I
must take care of that stupid pot dog
Edgar how frustrating is that I swear
someone has kidnapped Edgar he was way
too lazy to walk anywhere my cell I saw
him near the east gate would you be so
kind as to look for him
alright we got to find Edgar gamers oh
he's so cute
Hey all right this is the healing
fountain poop fountain nice and guess
who this is
you'll never guess all your fat oh hi
Alan listen they say the grounds are
rotting because of a malleable I can
never say they were malevolent green
wizard and I miss my little brother so
much mozzie I'm so sorry I see so you
can buy spells from Marcia freeze fart
power fart hell fart all epic farts I
can buy a scroll pack I'll get a scroll
pack I'm rich health part so you can
heal your poops freeze fire freezes
poops
power fart unleashes the city of broku
increased the attack of your team with
the fumes of brain ancestors I can
relate to all these poops sensors
I sense a soul in search of poop coins
so this is your skill tree I can upgrade
my poop so now I can make three poops
poops become stronger mighty poop
I haven't seen some of the finalized
artworks that's why I'm laughing
really good on the improvements like up
with upgrade my poop for a while okay
man I'm so proud of Simon and Oktar for
making this game they worked really hard
on it the goal of the game is that you
obviously we wanted to game to be
freeing so as many of you bros can play
it as possible but and the goal is but
get it haha so that you can finish the
game without having to pay for any items
look at you here comes a true hero in
terminated farth empowers to you during
my walks across the tombs of broke poop
I came into possession of large
quantities of fought games for the price
of just 30 poop coins you may enter the
lottery to win a beautiful fat game a
lottery ticket for a magnificent crystal
poop is just 30 coins feeling lucky yeah
sure wanna this is the system we added
after you die in the game you get to
scroll the wheel if you want Hey look we
got a carrot
alright let's go save Edgar yeah it is
honestly a damn shame
I'm so sorry Apple users I can't believe
they denied our applications look how
cute the game is like what yeah
hopefully we can get that fixed as soon
as possible
alright so these gates you need a
certain amount of poop bye bye fart butt
crawl poopy poop snoop poop with a scoop
that's what inspired this game all right
we can poop one more time watch this
video get age-restricted by you to know
this poop
my say if you're low in resources it's
always good to go for the items around
you Hey look at that we got some wood
all right let's just keep going
nice oh my god a strange duck with an
aura of gold visited me in my dream and
mentioned you'd come take this powerful
Fox girl please
it will save you much crawling and has
no use in the wild bog speed tan fart
gas portal to poop town and back pure
magic with Greenpeace at forty spell
it's basically once you're deep in the
dungeon so you can teleport back to town
if you play these type of games before
you know you know what's up I don't have
to explain there's that Edgar could that
be Edgar no I heard you guys walking
around around me
we're form who go away Edgar I'm trying
to save the real Edgar all right
whatever again okay so this is the map
and it's our mission and then you can
see the over link as well if you want to
all right what do we have here this is
one of the buttons right yeah hmm you
need a big brain to play poopd all right
we got a lot of enemies here hold up let
me heal my poop's nice you really want
to make sure you take care of your poops
you don't want to just flush them down
the toilet or something like that now of
course this applies to real life as well
thank you brash all right we find the
second button nice here we go
I'm not even gonna ask what that is all
right oh god oh god oh god oh yeah let
me heal them nice damn they're really Oh
Pina goddamn oh god there's so many no
all right got to make another poop
all right here we go definitely gonna
use yes they're frozen suck it
come on poops come on
oh they keep spawning I think no wait
there's one more okay there we go come
on again save him
I'll make another poop meanwhile he's so
cute
we returned King Edgar woof woof
all right let's follow him back I'll
follow you anywhere a king yet Edgar
we're back Edgar thank you for bringing
Edgar back I'm talking to the pole by
the way I bet that evil wizard is behind
this if you have any any offal in the
future there's a visit do you have any
spare offer give so basically you can
give the items that you get from
creatures into Edgar's Bowl and he'll
give you coins and stuff in return Hey
look at that nice thank you so generous
edgert Wow
we can heal up at the poop fountain look
like we have a new quest over here oh
wow
Oh No the paw jobs
I know it's about house find Tom Batta
Batta okay let's go back in the hole
sorry gamers I just really have to poop
I'll be one second useful I never felt
more powerful as a gamer than playing
poop tea on the toilet obviously I
washed my hands thank you for asking I
don't know what it is about controlling
poop that is just so satisfying maybe
there's like a human trait that we all
have inside us a natural instinct
perhaps there we go
so these are spawners that's why you
need kill them so how do I get there
let's see here oh I see okay I'm really
glad we added the map
hey I'm calling my poop's there we go
why you stinking poops there we go this
is the way it again won one of my poops
dies it feels like one of my own
children has died you get such a strong
personal connection to them it just
can't happen
oh no no back up back up back up if they
explode they gas your poops that's right
they can gas your poops this is so sad
you got to wait for the gas oh god I got
it no no no oh god these are strong but
freeze you gotta get them first oh god
oh god I got okay one one day but freeze
poop while they're back though
I'll take damage I'll take the damage
okay okay no no the battle is lost I
gotta go back and prove you lose battles
just go back in poop gamers I should
have buffed them instead okay I'll buff
them there we go now go forth my poops
nope yeah there you go that's how it's
done okay
that was a lot easier my fish poop links
go forth no mercy oh god it runs through
run through
there it is there it get the spawner
very nice very nice okay let's go
through the height oh my god
it's Tom federal boob oh I didn't notice
you're my bad I'm Tom but the bottle and
I'm neither sad I'm testing a brand new
mellow Jewish fog when a nasty green
creature told my score apart bring me
back my symphony or I will be in agony
sob sob sob alright sounds like a job
for a gamer gamers I still don't have
the required poop for the golden poop
one day I'll have golden poops alright
looks like we'll have to go up here no
no come back
whoo that was close Riven but in fat oh
and in fire good good one guys oh no no
no no oh god no they're all gonna die
this is so sad oh my god what a tragedy
oh my god I can't believe me oh my god
my own boobs
they were like a father to me oh I see
her on the map I'm supposed to go this
way there we go
nice all right we got his fiddle piece
of symphony hey hey you are without my
guess gaseous Symphony the joys of life
shall be cease to be sob he's so cute
dude I have it for you dumbass oh three
Scrolls oh okay oh my god
alright we're gonna have to use two
farts Scrolls on this one all right call
the mecha and then attack with all your
might Koopalings all right so now buff
attack and then freeze go go please Oh
God go come on Pope Martin get the spawn
yeah yeah yeah poops ya get ya got the
poop scroll bard thing I don't know what
this is hey poops goes hard fart health
fart alright where's the other one it's
over here okay through here oh god no no
follow me poop alright attack the green
Thanks
oh no no oh god no alright it's okay we
can make some sacrifices to the bowl
yes oh god we lost so much I'm so poor
now thanks Edgar alright we can head
back though it's alright I didn't open
the shortcut I'm such an idiot I should
have used to poop scroll to teleport
back
I'm sorry gamers oh my god my dead
carcass
god I hate how strong they are all right
let's go through the butthole what a
funky area we got shrooms we got all
kinds of stuff Wow
no get them don't let them hatch oh god
we got to get through there oh god oh
god oh god he has to poop scroll don't
do it poopy
you're crazy oh nice oh it's an evil
NoHo okay here we go
this will be it cut all right we got to
pull in we got a pulling attack nice all
right let's just go yeah more poops
oh god it's one versus one yeah that's
the last poo and he died in the process
that's so sad oh my god
I got a poop some more when in doubt
just keep booing that's what I always
said that's been my life motto it worked
out so far okay oh did I find a secret
place I think I did all right
nice oh oh oh my god well well well
developers think they can hide stuff
from me I don't think so
all right let's go through wait what is
this I don't even know what what this is
I feel like we should head back though
I'll do this later
all right let's use the town fart and
let's go where should we go
where's Tom fiddle but over here nice
okay nice and we can talk to you Oh -
wonderful gift you bring I can't wait
for soon I will again sing Edgar has
been taken you say then seek out but a
deal for help right away
oh yeah fine but yeah let's go back to
town it's a very it's a long game and I
could play all day it's super fun to
play I am so proud of ball where the
developers for making this it's it's
been so fun to see the game progress and
what they managed to accomplish with
such a small team and yeah I'm just
super proud of it I hope you guys will
like it download link in description
I think especially since Apple doesn't
want to accept the game so far it's
always gonna take a huge toll so if you
guys want to check it out I think that
would be really cool thank you
smash like if you enjoyed this video and
I see you guys tomorrow bye bye Hado now
excuse me I got some more pooping to do